mit has some of the world's greatest
scientists working on autism research
and this new Center was established to
find all new research directions by
those scientists we're going to apply
revolutionary new approaches in biology
to understanding autism so gene therapy
is a type of treatment that aims to
correct problems that occur in your DNA
code my name is omar badeah I'm an MD
PhD student at MIT and Harvard and
Jonathan Guzman Berg is my work spouse
you know one of the technologies we've
really been developing is this new RNAi
I do think technology called repair and
repair is a system for taking a specific
letter and changing it to a different
letter and so one really exciting thing
you could imagine is using our new
technology we could screen the hundreds
or thousands of mutations you've seen in
patients with autism in a dish or some
sort of model and actually try to
understand what are the most relevant
mutations what pathways they act through
and when you get that better
understanding start to have a map for
building better treatments so we are
specifically looking at how the immune
activation during pregnancy can lead to
brain disorders such as autism in
offspring we would like to understand
how the gut microbiome in the mother's
body actually can modulate does the
entire process and we want to ask
whether we can take advantage of this
process to either prevent or treat the
development of autism hey I'm Tobias
Kaiser I work in cooking Frank's lab and
I'm also the tan yang fellows my goals
are similar to those of most research
you want to change the world in some way
so I'm doing two things mainly one us I
understand a gene that's highly
implicated and not some better and the
second is that we try to develop gene
therapies for those disorders so what
I'm really hoping is that as we focus on
one disorder we can actually expand
these and generalize some of these
strategies also title disorders
so autism is a really interesting puzzle
I'm AJ Haskins I work in this building
for labs that recruit individuals with
autism so Dima and I have worked on a
couple of projects together recruiting
individuals with autism to do brain
imaging studies it's really hard to
recruit and bring in participants into
the lab for a study and so we often end
up with small samples and the sample is
not representative of the whole spectrum
what we are trying to do is to aggregate
data from various labs at MIT but
eventually various labs from all over
the world ultimately to address a few of
the challenges of autism research you
know when you put the very best people
on to a problem and you give them all
the resources they need to solve that
problem I can't help but be hopeful I
think we're entering a new era of autism
research and the end point is going to
be new therapies
[Music]